nadie se sorprende aquí echarme el set
de que la cop 27 se alargue algo que ha
sido confirmado por algunos de los
negociadores que siguen definiendo
detalles del texto final que tendrá que
ser aprobado por todos para que pueda
finalizar esta Cumbre el tema principal
de desacuerdo es la creación de un
mecanismo de financiación para las
pérdidas y daños sufridos derivados de
la crisis climática en un penúltimo
boceto se daban tres opciones para la
creación de este mecanismo una crearla
en esta misma cop dos hacerlo en la del
año que viene o tres una última opción
en la que no se crearía un fondo sino
que se hablaría de otras maneras de
financiar estos costes un pequeño avance
se dio cuando la Unión Europea afirmó su
voluntad de crear este mecanismo pero
precisando aunque sin nombres que las
grandes economías deberían invertir
dinero algo a lo que China o India que
ahora son grandes contaminantes o países
del Golfo que son grandes economías se
oponen por no considerar que son ellos
los responsables históricos del
calentamiento global y del cambio
climático además la Unión Europea
pretende que el abanico perdonantes a
este fondo se amplíe Más allá de los
países e incluso a grandes industrias
contaminantes como la Aviación el
transporte marítimo o las petroleras
escuchemos
la industria global del petróleo y el
gas ha tenido ingresos netos este año de
3,9 billones de dólares el doble que el
año pasado creo que es justo que hagan
una contribución hacia el financiamiento
que necesitamos para la escala de las
pérdidas y daños que vamos a requerir
otro de los puntos pendientes por
discutir en estas negociaciones es si
incluir todos los combustibles fósiles y
no solo mencionar el carbón como está en
el texto que también se aprobó en 2021
en Glasgow una decisión que puede ser
difícil con la asistencia de más de 600
representantes o aliados de la industria
petrolera o del gas